Звичайний суботній ранок у Київському військовому ліцеї імені Івана Богуна.
В той час як їхні однолітки "на гражданці" ще сплять
або планують розваги на вихідні, ці п’ятнадцятирічні дівчата
розпочинають свій день із шикування на плацу та стройовим кроком прямують до тиру -
вивчати військову справу на уроках "Захисту Вітчизни".
Цієї суботи їх у ліцеїсток - аж три поспіль.
Я вже звикла до розкладу. Мені вже звично
вставати о сьомій,  робити фізичну зарядку,
потім кожного ранку ходити стройовим.
В принципі, військовий без режиму - це не військовий.
Аполлінарія Іванова - одна з двадцяти дівчат, яких цього року
прийняли до Київського військового ліцею і сформували з них окремий взвод -
вперше за більш ніж сімдесятирічну історію цього навчального закладу.
До Києва дівчина приїхала здалеку - із Сєвєродонецька Луганської області.
Що таке війна, Аполлінарія добре знає -
побачила її на власні очі ще десятирічною дитиною.
Каже, тодішні враження вплинули на її рішення пов’язати своє життя з військом.
Я зрозуміла, що треба теж захищати нашу землю -
як ті люди, які зараз захищають нас.
Саме завдяки ним ми живемо у спокої та мирі.
Я хочу саме на бойову спеціальність піти - снайпер-розвідник.
Саме працювати в полі.
Бо я себе не бачу сидячою за столом.
Я хочу бути потрібною своїй державі.
На відміну від деяких інших ліцеїсток, Аполлінарія не з родини військових.
Її батьки, які живуть у Сєвєродонецьку - цивільні.
Утім, доньку, яка побажала вступити до військового ліцею, вони підтримали.
Тож протягом двох років Аполлінарія та її товаришки по взводу житимуть у казармі
й окрім звичайної шкільної програми опановуватимуть військову справу.
Вчитимуться поводитися зі зброєю - та влучно стріляти.
Із влучною стрільбою у дівчат проблем немає.
Викладач "Захисту Вітчизни" Олександр Мельник розповідає,
що ліцеїстки стріляють не гірше, а подекуди навіть краще, ніж юнаки.
Майже половина дівчат сьогодні отримала найвищий бал -
а декого можна готувати на снайпера.
Дев’ять, вісім, сім - 25 очок.
Згідно нормативу це оцінка 12. А по п’ятибальній - п’ять.
На сьогодні кращий результат - 27.
Підполковник у відставці Олександр Мельник почав викладати у ліцеї
кілька років тому - коли тут навчались ще виключно юнаки.
Експеримент зі взводом дівчат колишній військовий цілком підтримує.
Вони відрізняються від хлопців чим - більше витримки, більше зібраності,
більша мотивація до навчання.
Нічого немає ганебного в тому, якщо у нас дівчата
будуть нарівні з хлопцями виконувати свій обов’язок
громадянина із захисту нашої вітчизни.
Ми маємо приклад багатьох держав світу - той же самий Ізраїль,
де є загальновійськова повинність.
У нас так само є дуже багато дівчат, які виконують свої обов’язки
в зоні проведення Операції об’єднаних сил
не гірше, ніж хлопці - а то і краще. Я сподіваюсь, що в найближчий час
перша жінка-генерал з’явиться в наших збройних силах.
Щоб потрапити до ліцею, дівчата нарівні з юнаками подолали неабиякий конкурс.
Складали іспити з математики, української та іноземної мови,
також тести з фізичної підготовки. Крім цього -  проходили психологічний профвідбір.
Різниці у військовій підготовці між юнаками і хлопцями немає.
Також ліцеїстки так само носять польові однострої -
і грають в ігри, які багато хто досі вважає чоловічими.
Я в футбол граю з дитинства - мені подобається як футбол, так і волейбол і баскетбол.
Мені здається, що види спорту поділяти
на чоловічі та жіночі - це неправильно.
Якщо жінка вміє грати у футбол, чому їй це забороняти
та казати, що це чоловіча справа.
Поки Аполлінарія та інші дівчата грають у футбол, питаємо їхніх одновзводниць,
що їх спонукало обрати військову кар’єру -
та про їхні враження від першого місяця у казармі.
У мене батько військовий.
Обидва дідусі у мене військові.
Захотілось продовжити династію військових.
Спочатку було важко - стройова підготовка по чотири або по п’ять годин.
Багато домашнього завдання спочатку було.
Але потім якось звикаєш і стає легше з кожним днем.
Все подобається. Життя по розпорядку - це не так важко,
це доволі-таки цікаво.
Плани на майбутнє?
я хочу вступити в льотне у Харкові.
Чому хтось так вирішив, що тільки чоловіки можуть захищати
свою землю, свою державу? Я вважаю, що це неправильно.
Може і жінка захищати.
Вона теж тут живе і це, мені здається, обов’язок кожного.
Насправді у мене завжди була мрія бути військовою, захищати Україну..
Після подій Євромайдану ця мрія укріпилась в стійкі наміри,
і ліцей дав мені можливість це здійснити.
Я люблю дисципліну - це мене захоплює.
Також я люблю сам культ захисту України.
Тут дійсно дуже серйозна дисципліна.
Великі навантаження з фізичної підготовки.
Це також допомагає гартувати себе.
Після закінчення військового ліцею хочу поступити
у Львівську академію Петра Сагайдачного -
або артилерія або психологія.
Ми сюди прийшли зламати стереотип про те,
що дівчата не можуть бути військовими.
Як важко зламати стереотипи і завоювати повагу жінкам в армії,
на собі відчула командир взводу дівчат Юлія Микитенко.
Її посада у ліцеї - це щось на кшталт класного керівника у цивільній школі,
пояснює вона. 24-річна лейтенантка, філологиня за освітою - ветеранка війни на Донбасі.
На сході Юлія Микитенко командувала розвідувальним взводом.
А з бойового підрозділу перевелась після того, як на фронті загинув її чоловік.
Сексизму дуже багато. Я рік пропрацювала на штабній посаді у бойовому підрозділі -
я була бухгалтером і діловодом.
Але коли я вже прийшла офіцером і стала на бойову посаду,
тоді навіть ті люди, які до мене добре ставились як до штабного працівника,
почали ставитись до мене трошки зверхньо, упереджено.
Казали: "Ти не можеш бути бойовим офіцером.
Ти взагалі офіцером не можеш бути. Ти - жінка, ти нічого не тямиш,
в тебе немає бойового досвіду, ти не знаєш, як рішення правильно  приймати.
І взагалі - у тебе місячні, які впливають на твій емоційний стан.
На те, щоб подолати старі ґендерні стереотипи в бойових умовах,
у  неї пішло чимало часу, розповідає Юлія Микитенко.
Її підопічним поталанило більше - адже у ліцеї майбутні офіцери та офіцерки
навчаються не лише військової справи, але й ґендерної рівності.
Хлопці дивляться на дівчат - а як це вони швидше шикуються, а як це вони швидше бігають,
а як це вони, зрештою, автомат швидше розбирають?
І це трошки їх підстьобує до покращення себе.
Але що думають про все це юнаки? Ідемо до казарми -
подивитись, як живуть ліцеїсти, та заодно спитати, як їм навчатись разом з дівчатами
і чи могли б вони уявити жінку своїм командиром.
Звичайно.
Це - проект нової армії і всі ми підтримуємо його.
Трошки незвично, але всі тут прихильники ґендерної рівності
і намагаються ставитись однаково як до чоловічої, так і до жіночої статі.
Так, авжеж. А що тут такого?
Я не бачу тут нічого такого дивного.
Країна рівних можливостей. Хоч генералом, хоч міністром, хоч головнокомандувачем.
Такі поняття як жінка-связист, жінка-радіст -
це все застаріла радянська армія.
В сучасній українській армії такого не має бути.
І якщо жінка заслуговує на високі генеральські погони -
вона абсолютно має право бути генералом.
Живуть юнаки і дівчата в однакових умовах -
на рівних ділять спартанський військовий побут та обмеження армійського життя.
Приміром - до складання присяги їх так само не відпускають у звільнення,
тож єдина можливість поспілкуватись з рідними протягом перших шести тижнів у ліцеї -
поки що коротка зустріч на КПП.
Або ж телефонний дзвінок після навчання - у вільний час.
Втім, ліцеїсток все це не лякає - адже мрія вступити
до військового вишу і стати офіцерками сильніша.
А викладачі тим часом кажуть: якщо цьогорічний експеримент
виявиться успішним, можуть набрати ще один взвод дівчат.
Адже місця у жіночий частині казарми вистачає.